foreign
this this sort of what I think is the
worst pandemic this sense of victimhood
is coming and rising to the top and it's
a it's a danger to our society today
you're seeing it right now unfortunately
uh this woke culture uh trying to uh
sort of inflict their views uh on on
other people who can't have a a
dissenting opinion and it's killing the
dialogue
and you've got the victims now becoming
the majority and when victims become the
majority you see the certain you know
the cancel culture uh coming around
being a warrior is about a mindset not
carrying a gun uh there's a difference
between War Fighters and warriors
they're not necessarily mutually
exclusive but all the people I served
with in the military were not Warriors
in fact the abundance of them were War
Fighters but just locked in mindset
there are some bad narratives out there
the sense of people telling others that
uh they have so little because somebody
else has so much and that's just not
true behind success there is stories and
trials and tribulation and resiliency
and people had to earn the the right to
where they're at and what what they have
whether that's possessions happiness
whatever it may be another form of
victimhood is entitlement you're
entitled to free money from the
government you're entitled to this or we
should take take from somebody else to
give you more and that is the ultimate
victim mentality it's saying I have no
control over my life another part of
victimhood is this fixed mindset I am
who I am and I can't improve so if it's
someone else's fault
we take a hit at social media there's
great things about social media but
there are also some bad things
and one of those bad things is everyone
has a microphone and you know what we've
seen with victimhood is social media in
a way uh promotes victimhood what people
understand is there's a difference
between victimhood and vulnerability and
vulnerability is one of the most
admirable traits any Warrior can have
but when somebody does it time and time
again and they get this attention of oh
poor you and you know you deserve better
it's not your fault well that becomes
addictive because they're getting
attention in a negative way and so they
become addicted to that victimhood and
the attention that it gets them the the
sort of affirmation that hey there
nothing is it within their control that
they can remain lazy that they they they
don't have to take the hard steps to
turn their lives over
you look at the public education our
kids are not being taught attributes or
how to lead or accountability or
discipline they're not being taught
those things instead they're being
taught things again that reinforce that
they're victims and uh that they they
aren't in control of their circumstances
the problem is us it's my generation
it's not the uh the kid it's being
forced upon them we I talk about you
know 11 principles I learned from from
these Warriors Warriors one of which the
Marine Corps in the US Army Teach as one
of the the foundations of leadership is
set the example
when we see leadership at its worst
where it should be at its best the
national capital region Washington DC
they are setting a poor example for the
Next Generation to follow there's zero
close to zero accountability amongst our
national leaders it's no surprise when
the work habits of the younger
generation are different we're not
creating a generation of Warriors
everyday Warriors
Warriors within their respective
professions instead were creating
victims who think they're entitled to
certain things and that nothing is their
fault
we need to look heavily at our education
system we need to look heavily at our
families on what we're teaching our
children and preparing them to face the
challenges which are probably going to
be more Steep and severe than what we've
faced but preparing them to answer those
challenges and drive America forward
into the next century
hard choices lead to an easy life easy
choices lead to an unmemorable life that
nobody would want to read about how do
you climb a mountain one step at a time
how do you build a business one brick at
a time how do you change your life
one day at a time so don't expect to be
in a bad bad space and then you know
expect changes overnight that's not
going to happen take it one day at a
time one step at a time and
incrementally expose yourself to change
inner you know incrementally expose
yourself to discomfort things that make
you uneasy things that give you anxiety
like if it's speaking in front of people
and before you know it after a year
you're going to look back and you're
going to see how many steps you've taken
how many victories you've incurred
failure that you've learned from and
your life will be in a better position
but nobody can help you
but you